Wollen die wissen, wie meine Mundwinkel am Südkreuz rumhängen?
Also ja, das sind also das sind alles Überlegungen und Forschungen, die die ganze Zeit stattfinden. Also was für Informationen kann man eigentlich aus so einer anderen Erinnerung von Pixeln, also ein Video, rausholen? Und momentan geht es da so, die Wünsche und die Vorstellungen sind momentan noch so, okay, da werden also Objekte irgendwie erkannt und Personen im Bild. Gehört das irgendwie zueinander? Und wenn jetzt jemand ein Objekt, zum Beispiel eine Tasche oder sowas, stehen lässt und sich von der entfernt, dann soll das halt irgendwie erkannt werden. Also schon irgendwie Bildanalysen und sowas. Und natürlich ist dann denkbar, das sind ja dann nur noch Software Updates, dass man dann irgendwie auch noch überprüft. Aber worauf ich eigentlich gerade hinaus wollte, ist, wenn man also davon ausgehen muss, dass irgendwie das Verhalten die ganze Zeit analysiert wird, dann passt man sein Verhalten auch an eine irgendwie geartete Idee an, was da jetzt gerade kontrolliert wird. Und wenn man es nicht genau weiß, dann nimmt man halt irgendwas an, auch unterbewusst vielleicht.
Und deswegen passiert einfach doch konkret was mit den Menschen, die da heute schon lange waren.
Genau, selbst wenn jede einzelne Kamera irgendwie legitim ist, aber in der Masse wird es halt einen bestimmten Einfluss auf eine Gesellschaft haben, die sich irgendwie durch, die in so einer Stadt lebt.
Und ich find's auch total wichtig. Bei diesen Diskussionen hört man ja, also hören wir auch öfters mal, dass dann Leute sagen, nö wieso in der Kamera, ich verhalte mich da nicht anders. Und das ist natürlich ein sehr, sehr egoistische Sicht an der Stelle. Also ich hab jetzt zum Beispiel persönlich auch kein Problem, wenn überall nur Treppen sind. Ja gut, es gibt aber auch Menschen, die haben mit Treppen ein Problem. Sagen wir jetzt einfach, ist mir doch egal? Oder sagen wir, wir wollen aber auch zahlenmäßig Minderheiten mitnehmen. Wir wollen einfach eine pluralistische Gesellschaft haben. Wir wollen eben auch die Leute, die jetzt nicht so irgendwie alphamäßig unterwegs sind und wenn sie eine Kamera sehen, da irgendwie noch reinwinken oder so. Sondern wir wollen auch die Leute, die sagen, ich bin irgendwie so ein bisschen trau mich nicht usw. Wie auch immer. Wir wollen ja einen freiheitlichen Raum schaffen und erhalten, in dem sich alle wohlfühlen. Und wenn ich jetzt das Glück habe, irgendwie ein bisschen größeres Ego zu haben, ja, ist doch schön, aber es sind nicht alle so. Und das ist glaube ich so ein Punkt, wo man immer, wenn man sich so eine Gesellschaft aus starken, gesunden, irgendwie jungen Menschen vorstellt, dann sieht die natürlich anders aus, als wenn man eine pluralistische Gesellschaft hat, wo auch Leute z.B. denken, dass sie Stigmata hätten, weil sie irgendwie aussehen, weil sie irgendwie, die sich dann vielleicht nicht trauen. Und an die muss man halt auch denken. Wir wollen ja da zusammen irgendwie dran arbeiten. Und eine zweite Sache, die mir auch total wichtig ist, das hat ja Ben auch schon gesagt, wir bauen eine Infrastruktur auf. Also wir haben ja jetzt nicht horizontal und vertikale Gewaltenteilung in Deutschland, wo es Verhinderung von Machtzentren usw. weil wir dem Staat so toll vertrauen können. Also ich meine, es ist genau das gleiche in den USA, es ist gerade irgendwie das große Erwachen, wir statten hier irgendwie die Geheimdienste mit voll den krassen Möglichkeiten aus, weil wir sind ja volles demokratisches Land usw. Und da wird halt jemand gewählt, wo man sagt, hups, hätten wir mal irgendwie da nichts hingestellt. Und in Deutschland, wenn man sich die Parlamente anguckt, hat ganz viele Gründe usw. Aber ich find's gut, bestimmte Möglichkeiten zu begrenzen und einfach staatlichen Stellen nicht zur Verfügung zu stellen, um einfach zu sagen, ja, wer weiß, wer später da ist usw. Insbesondere, und da muss man immer wieder darauf hinweisen, wenn es gar nichts bringt. Das ist bei dieser ganzen Debatte eigentlich der krasseste Punkt, an dem man immer wieder zurückkommen muss. Aber auch davor, was du gerade meintest, ist der Gedanke, institutionelle Macht zu begrenzen und Schlussstrich irgendwo zu ziehen. Da sind wir genau an dieser Schnittstelle von Gesellschaft und Informatik, die heute Abend unser Ausgangspunkt war. Ich fasse noch mal kurz zusammen, oder sag noch mal hallo. Ihr seid im Chaos Radio, Chaos Radio Nr. 245, mit dem Forum Informatikerinnen für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung im CCCB in Berlin. Wir haben es kurz nach 11. Eigentlich müssen wir langsam mal hier in einer Form weitermachen. Wir haben ja jedes Mal auch im Chaos Radio, um ein bisschen noch den Blick über den Tellerrand des aktuellen Themas zu schmeißen. Nerd-News und die Nerd-News gibt es jetzt um kurz nach 11, zusammengestellt von Mo, vorgetragen heute von Helena.
Am 15. Mai findet im Bayerischen Landtag die zweite Lesung des Polizeiaufgabengesetzes, kurz PAG, statt. Das PAG erlaubt die polizeiliche Nutzung von Trojanern, Kontensperrungen ohne Richtervorbehalt, präventive Zwangsentschlüsselung, Standortüberwachung und vieles mehr. Deshalb rufen 42 bürgerrechts- und zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen sowie Parteien zu einer Großdemonstration in München auf. Am 10. Mai will das Bündnis auf die Straße gehen. Zudem wurden Verfassungsklagen angekündigt. Immer mehr Landwirte in Deutschland klagen über eine zu langsame Internetverbindung. Nach einer repräsentativen Umfrage des Bauernverbandes sind 77 Prozent der Landwirte mit ihrem Zugang zum Netz unzufrieden. Der Präsident des Deutschen Bauernverbandes, Joachim Rukwied, sagte, bis 2025 flächendeckend ein gigabitfähiges Netz ausgebaut zu haben, sei nicht ambitioniert genug. So verliere man Zeit und vergebe Chancen. Die gemeinnützige Zertifizierungsstelle Let's Encrypt ist ein voller Erfolg. Nach nur zwei Jahren stellt sie aktuell über die Hälfte aller TLS-Zertifikate aus. Diese dienen zur Verschlüsselung der Kommunikation zwischen Servern und Endanwendungen wie Browsern. Let's Encrypt wurde unter anderem von Mozilla, der Electronic Frontier Foundation und Akamai gegründet. Sie vergibt seit April 2016 kostenfreie Zertifikate an Webseitenbetreiber. Wie die Financial Times berichtet, verhandeln Vodafone und der US-Konzern Liberty Global über eine mögliche Übernahme von Unity Media. Die Gespräche seien bereits im fortgeschrittenen Stadium und eine Einigung könne im Laufe der kommenden zwei Wochen erfolgen. Ein Sprecher der Telekom äußerte Bedenken und wies darauf hin, dass eine Remonopolisierung der Kabelnetze von Experten zu Recht kritisch bewertet werde. Im Gegensatz zu früheren Bemühungen könnte der Deal bei den Regulierungsbehörden diesmal durchgehen. Offenbar wünscht die EU starke Anbieter, um den ins Hintertreffen geratenden Breitbandausbau voranzubringen.
Helena, mit den Nerd-News im Chaosradio, wo wir das Thema Südkreuz doch noch einmal kurz aufmachen und abschließen müssen, haben wir gerade hier während die News liefen festgestellt. Wir reden ja hier im Chaosradio Nummer 245 gerade über die Videoüberwachung mit Gesichtserkennung am Berliner Bahnhof Südkreuz, die aus vielerlei Gründen problematisch ist. Darüber haben wir gerade schon eine ganze Weile gesprochen. Jetzt ist das Schöne, es gibt ja doch ein paar Zahlen. Du hast gerade gesagt, man erfährt gar nicht so viel von dem, was die da an Ergebnissen testen. Aber ein bisschen was gibt es doch, um nachzuvollziehen, wie viel das Ganze eigentlich bringt.
Genau, also wir haben halt eben nicht diese ganzen Informationen und Studien tatsächlich einzeln bekommen. Aber wenn man mal die Zahlen, die jetzt einfach in so Pressemitteilungen hochrechnet und mal so ein paar sinnvolle Annahmen trifft.
Also quasi die Zahlen, mit denen die prahlen.
Genau, also es geht sozusagen ja um die Erkennungsrate. Also wenn da 100 Leute langlaufen, wie viele Leute werden richtig erkannt und wie viele werden falsch eingeordnet. Und diese Erkennungsraten, die sie jetzt verbal einfach so veröffentlicht haben, die Deméziers sozusagen in einem Besuch mal irgendwann am Südkreuz postuliert hat, ohne dass man sie jetzt nachprüfen konnte. Wenn man sich das mal durchrechnet. Also wir haben da eine bestimmte Erkennungsrate. Das hab ich jetzt grad nicht im Kopf. Irgendwie waren es so 75 Prozent. Aber wenn man jetzt mal davon einfach ausgeht und man macht mal einfache Zahlen. Wir haben 160 Bahnhöfe in Berlin. Und bei jeder... In jedem Bahnhof gibt es vier Rolltreppen. Und alle paar Sekunden kommt dann ein Mensch, der da so eine Rolltreppe runterfährt. Dann hört man... 1920 Alarme pro 30 Minuten. Also warte mal.
Alarme bedeutet, das System meint, einen Menschen erkannt zu haben, der in der Datenbank steht, weil er ein gefährlicher Typ sein könnte.
Genau. Also wir haben einerseits eine große Zahl, eine relativ große Zahl, die sich hochrechnet, weil da einfach so viele Leute über diese Rolltreppen gehen, wenn man es halt wirklich ausrollt in ganz Berlin. Da ist halt super viele, ganz, ganz oft werden Leute, die eigentlich gesucht werden, nicht erkannt. Aber noch viel krasser ist es, dass wir halt andauernd Fehlalarme haben von Leuten, die verwechselt werden.
Also weil einfach, es gibt nur eine bestimmte Erfolgsquote. Das heißt, es gibt auf jeden Fall alle so und so viele Menschen, jemanden, der erkannt wird, obwohl er gar nicht erkannt werden sollte. Und das passiert derart oft, weil da so viele Menschen langlaufen, dass man aus dem Scannen und Nachgucken gar nicht mehr rauskommt, weil auf meinem Schreibtisch als Security Super Advisor dauernd das rote Lämpchen angeht und es rumpiept.
Genau, genau. Und wenn man das jetzt noch mal hochrechnet auf alle großen deutschen Städte oder so was, dann würden wir aus den Fehlalarm gar nicht mehr rauskommen. Und das macht dieses Szenario, was man vielleicht im Kopf hat von wegen, wir suchen da jemanden und der ist ganz böse und wir stellen überall Kameras auf und wenn wir den finden, dann können wir den ganz schnell festnehmen, führt das total ad absurdum.
Und das macht eben dann diese Zahl, was du vorhin meintest, 99 von 100 werden korrekt erkannt, plötzlich zu einer Zahl, die gar nicht mehr so geil klingt, wie sie auf den ersten Blick klingt.
Genau, und das sind ja Laborbedingungen.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein Punkt, das hat auch ein bisschen was mit einem Grundverständnis von Biometrie zu tun, was auch in der Politik sehr wenig verbreitet ist. Weil erstens Biometrie ist immer eine Frage von Wahrscheinlichkeiten. Wenn du ein Passwort eingibst, das ist halt richtig oder falsch. Biometrie heißt immer, du hast Wahrscheinlichkeiten von Übereinstimmungen. Und wenn dann jemand sich vor die Kamera stellt und sagt, ja, wir haben eine Erkennungsrate von X, dann heißt es, von den Leuten, die man sucht, erwischt man so und so viel. Was immer unten runterfällt, ist, wie viele Leute werden erkannt, obwohl sie gar nicht in der Datenbank stehen. Also es gibt sozusagen bei Biometrie zwei Arten von Fehlern. Also wie oft erkennt man jemanden nicht, den man sucht, und wie oft erkennt man jemanden, den man gar nicht sucht. Und wenn man die beiden zusammenrechnet, da muss man halt ein bisschen Statistik verstehen, dann merkt man, wie wahnsinnig das eigentlich ist, solche Technik flächendeckend einzusetzen. Aber das hat eben auch ein bisschen was mit dem, was wir als FIF machen, zu tun. Da muss man halt aufs Detail gucken und tatsächlich verstehen. Da muss man was von Statistik verstehen, da muss man was von Biometrie verstehen, da muss man was von irgendwie False Positives, False Negatives verstehen usw. Und ganz zum Schluss kommt dann eben raus, dass eigentlich es viel mehr, wahnsinnig viel mehr Fehlalarme gibt, als tatsächlich sinnvolle Erkennungsraten. Und das ist so ein Punkt, eigentlich so eine Sternstunde, finde ich immer, wenn Ben da quasi dran arbeitet, wo man quasi sich eine Sache anguckt, dann tief einsteigt, irgendwie da die Fakten, die man kennt, seziert, das Wissen, was man hat seziert und dann irgendwann wieder hochsteigt und dieses Ergebnis dann wieder anwendet auf den Einsatzzweck und merkt, das haut überhaupt nicht hin. Ja, zumal es ja Zahlen sind, die da offiziell von Herrn de Maizière dann gesagt worden sind in der Hoffnung, dass diese Zahlen toll ankommen bei den Leuten.
Genau, die wurden ziemlich bejubelt, diese Zahlen.
Weil keiner sich diese doch einfach ein bisschen komplizierten Gedanken macht, die du dir dann an der Stelle gemacht hast.
Genau, das wird dann einfach ganz anders dargestellt. Da heißt es dann so, na ist doch besser als nichts. So, ist doch besser als wenn wir die laufen lassen.
Und in dem Fall wäre aber besser als das, wenn der Mensch im Sicherheitsbüro nichts an Fehlalarm bekäme, weil er sich dann auf andere Dinge konzentrieren könnte. Und diese Technik würde ihn völlig in Konfusion führen.
Eigentlich zeigt es, dass diese Technik nicht dafür da ist, jemanden zu schnappen oder so, sondern um Daten zu sammeln. Um zu wissen, wer wann wo wie lang läuft. Um Informationen zu sammeln. Und da geht es eben nicht um Sicherheit. Und nicht um das Auftauchen von einem Terroristen, der sich vorher in eine Kapuze übergezogen hat.
Das ist die Gesichtserkennung in der Videoüberwachung am Südkreuz. Ein Testlauf läuft da gerade seit August schon. Wie lange weißt du das im Kopf?
Das haben sie jetzt einmal verlängert.
Also läuft noch ein bisschen wahrscheinlich. Da sind 300 Testpersonen, deren Gesichter in einer Datenbank vorliegen, die jedes Mal erkannt werden sollen, wenn sie am Südkreuz langlaufen. Und das Ganze eben als Testlauf gedacht für möglicherweise irgendwann mal ganz viel von dieser modernen Videoüberwachungstechnik mit Gesichtserkennung, die unter so einem Sicherheitsgedanken politisch verkauft wird.
Und was man sich merken kann, Gesichtserkennung funktioniert nur, wenn man mitmacht.
Also ist es eigentlich, was ich wirklich mitnehme heute als Kernerkenntnis, man kann noch so viel drüber reden, es ist eigentlich ein Ding, was nicht mal funktioniert.
Nicht so, wie es begründet wird.
Hier ist das Chaosradio. Wir hören ein Stück Musik, Netzmusik unter Creative Commons Lizenz. Das ist Forest Music von Lifeform. Und danach reden wir weiter über Überwachung. Diesmal dann über Überwachung mittels Bundestrojaner. Es wird immer schöner heute Abend. Wenn diese Melodie kommt, wisst ihr schon, was läuft. Chaos Radio, heute Ausgabe Nummer 245, live aus dem Chaos Computer Club in Berlin in der Marienstraße. Ich bin sehr froh, dass wir heute nicht bei Fritz sind, was wir ja immer den anderen Monat sind, alle zwei Monate. Denn da hätten wir jetzt schon auf die Finger bekommen, weil wir so wild hier mit der Zeit umgehen. Also jetzt 20 nach 11, wir haben jetzt quasi gerade so Halbzeit gemacht, obwohl wir nur noch bis 12 reden können. Aber es war ja auch ein guter Grund. Wir haben gerade hier den Südkreuz und die Videoüberwachung mit Gesichtserkennung dort ein bisschen ausführlich auseinandergenommen.
Verlegt.
Mussten wir tun, weil das ja auch wirklich ein Ding ist, wo man ein paar Sachen kapieren muss erst mal. Und ich, also ich möchte noch mal kurz sagen, meine Erkenntnis von heute ist wirklich, die können reden so viel sie wollen, es funktioniert noch nicht mal. Wien ist nicht so wie es soll.
Wer sich dafür noch weiter interessiert, wir haben einen Twitter-Account unterstrich Südkreuz mit UE.
Ach nur dafür?
Ja, wir haben mehrere Twitter-Accounts.
Ihr habt also einen eigenen Twitter-Account zu Südkreuz. Unterstrich Südkreuz mit UE. Aber lasst uns jetzt nicht schon wieder ins Südkreuz abdriften. Wir bleiben dabei, wie ihr euch am FIF, ich sag's nochmal, wir haben heute Gäste hier vom Forum Informatikerinnen für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung. Ben ist da, Rainer ist da und zugeschaltet aus der Nähe von Bremen immer noch Creo. Bist du noch wach? Ein Glück. Wir reden noch weiter über Überwachung und eigentlich bleiben wir sogar so ein bisschen in der gleichen Richtung, weil es geht nochmal darum, wenn der Staat im weitesten Sinne die Menschen, die in dem Staat leben, überwachen, ausspionieren möchte. Und zwar reden wir jetzt über Trojaner, über Staats- Bundes- Trojaner. Das sind ja alles so Wörter, die schon seit Jahren irgendwie rumgeistern und die immer, ich find, fast so ein bisschen bedrohlich klingen. Da ist jetzt Rainer unser Experte. Warum eigentlich? Weil ich mich mit dem Thema schon eine ganze Weile auseinandersetze, mindestens vielleicht so acht Jahre. Ich hab dazu auch publiziert, hab meine Diplomarbeit genau dazu geschrieben, bin auch in so einigen Arbeitskreisen, die diese Thematik behandeln, auch zum Beispiel mit dem BSI, also Bundesamt für Sicherheit und Informationstechnik und so in anderen Runden unterwegs. Was ist denn jetzt gerade so das Ding, was uns in dieser Trojan-Thematik beschäftigen sollte? Gibt es gerade aktuelle Entwicklungen oder ist das mehr so ein allgemeines Ding, was immer wieder relevant ist? Also es gibt schon etwas, womit man sich beschäftigen sollte, und zwar es gibt immer so schrittweise, mal ging es um die Bundestrojaner und dann gibt es jetzt verschiedene Bundesländer, die darüber nachdenken, sich solche Trojaner zuzulegen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel Hessen oder so, oder Bremen jetzt auch gerade. Ich glaube, was man gerade beachten muss, ist, dass es da so eine Art implizite Strategie gerade gibt. Also viele wollen diese Trojaner haben und jedes einzelne Bundesland sagt, ja, wäre doch super, wenn wir das hätten. Und dann sagt hier wieder ein Landesverfassungsschutz, oh, wäre doch super, wenn wir das hier hätten. Dann sagt halt irgendwie die Bundeswehr ist auch super, wenn wir sowas mal hätten. Und jeder denkt so für sich alleine. Und zum Schluss merkt man, dass wir hier komplett hochgerüstet sind und haben sozusagen ganz viel Geld und ganz viel Energie drauf verwendet, Rechner zu hacken, also aktiv Unsicherheit zu erzeugen. Und das ist, glaube ich, so ein Punkt, wo man immer drauf gucken muss. Es gibt so Einzelfälle, mit denen beschäftigen wir uns auch. Man muss auch immer an jedem Einzelfall da ordentlich sich mit beschäftigen. Wir waren zum Beispiel auch Sachverständige beim Hessentrojaner, zum Beispiel im Landtag. Man muss sich an jeder Stelle damit beschäftigen. Aber das Akute entsteht meiner Ansicht nach dadurch, dass sich insgesamt so eine Richtung formt, in die sich das entwickelt. Dann nochmal back to basic. Also, Bundestrojaner oder Landestrojaner, zum Beispiel in Hessen, heißt irgendwelche deutschen Geheimdienste, schreiben Computerprogramme, mit denen sie Dinge tun? Genau, also die Grundidee, ganz einfach runtergebrochen ist, früher hat man quasi so telefoniert. Und wenn es jetzt irgendwie Anzeichen dafür gab, dass da irgendwie krumme Dinge getan werden von bestimmten Leuten, dann konnte man eben zum, ich sag jetzt mal, ein Anführungsstrichen, Fräulein im Amt gehen, also was weiß ich, zur Telekom und sagen, ich würde jetzt gerne diesen Anschluss überwachen. Dann kann man da irgendwie sein technisches Ohr ranlegen und dann können eben die Behörden da eben mithören. Jetzt ist so, dass wir irgendwie die sogenannten Over-the-Top-Dienste haben, sowas wie Signal oder Whatsapp oder wie sie nicht alle heißen. Und die können jetzt aber irgendwie Ende zu Ende verschüsseln. Das heißt also, wenn man jetzt irgendwie das Ohr an die Leitung legt, dann kommt da nur Kauderwelsch raus. Also denkt sich der findige Kriminalbeamte, Mensch, aber an den Endpunkten liegen doch die Daten lesbar, offensichtlich lesbar, weil ja die Leute, die miteinander kommunizieren, die müssen sie auch lesen können. Also sind wir total schlau und brechen einfach in die Endgeräte ein und lesen die da mit. So, das ist so die grobe Idee. Also das Problem ist, wenn ich auf meinem Smartphone WhatsApp benutze, dann ist inzwischen standardmäßig alles, was ich per WhatsApp verschicke, verschlüsselt und zwar Ende zu Ende. Das bedeutet nicht mal WhatsApp in der Mitte kann meine Nachrichten entschlüsseln und lesen. Die können zwar irgendwelche Metadaten speichern und mitbekommen, aber die wissen nicht, was ich jemandem schreibe. Genauso ist es, wenn ich E-Mails verschlüsselt verschicke oder so. Und die Idee ist jetzt, dass man sich sozusagen auf mein Smartphone oder meinen Computer hackt und darauf wartet, bis mein Gerät, das darf das ja, diese Nachricht entschlüsselt hat und dann sozusagen guckt, ach was steht denn da auf dem Bildschirm, der kann es ja auch lesen, der Konrad, aha, das ist die Nachricht. So geht's? Genau, das ist die Idee. Und da spielt jetzt wieder so eine gewisse weltsichtende Rolle, die halt sagt, oh mein Gott, immer mehr Leute verschlüsseln. Und dann hat man wieder, so ein bisschen wie bei Südkreuz, wird so eine Bedrohungsszenario aufgebaut. Oh mein Gott, wir werden jetzt blind als Sicherheitsbehörden. Also müssen wir in so einer Art geistigen Ausnahmezustand alle Mittel irgendwie verwenden, um doch noch an diese Nachrichten ranzukommen. Na gut, aber ist es nicht ein bisschen so, dass man vergleichsweise blind wird als Geheimdienstmensch mit der Zeit? Ja, ich glaube, als Geheimdienstmensch wird man blind. Nein, ich meine, die Technik verbessert sich. Die Leute können auf ganz neuen Wegen kommunizieren. Es wird komplizierter nachzuvollziehen und mitzuhören. Total. Das ist natürlich eine spannende Sache. Das nennt sich auch in der US-Amerikanischen Debatte das sogenannte Going Dark Problem. Also dass man sozusagen, dass irgendwie alles schwarz wird, weil man nichts mehr erkennen kann. Es gibt dazu aber auch schon universitäre Forschung, die angestellt worden ist, wo sich dann gezeigt hat, ja, einerseits sorgt diese Technisierung und Verschlüsselung und so weiter dafür, dass die konkreten Unterhaltungen nicht mehr sichtbar sind. Aber andererseits ist an so vielen Ecken und Enden andere Technologie, die jetzt aufkommt, irgendwie vom Temperatursensor bis zu irgendwelchen anderen Fahrkartenautomaten, dass es ganz viele andere und neue Wege gibt, an ähnliche Informationen ranzukommen, um trotzdem sozusagen den Sicherheitsbeamten da irgendwie, dass sie ihre Arbeit immer noch gut machen können. Okay, also es gibt sozusagen eine Verbesserung der Kommunikationstechnik in Sachen Verschlüsselung, wodurch den Sicherheitsbehörden Daten weggenommen werden. Aber gleichzeitig, genauso wegen der technischen Weiterentwicklung, gibt es auch überall neue Datenquellen, die aufploppen. Und eigentlich im Endeffekt sogar mehr Daten, mit denen Geheimdienste arbeiten können heutzutage. Exakt, genau. Und man kann sich das ja auch anschauen. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass irgendwie die ganzen Kriminalitätsraten so irgendwie mit der Verschlüsselung korrelieren. Und plötzlich ist irgendwie alles ganz furchtbar. Und was man, glaube ich, auch mit beachten muss, man könnte die Diskussion ja führen, wenn man sagt, naja gut, bringt das was oder bringt das nichts? Aber es gibt noch einen ganz entscheidenden, ganz entscheidenden, man kann es vielleicht Kollateralschaden nennen. Und zwar, man kann in der Regel in solche Systeme nur einbrechen, wenn man Sicherheitsprobleme dieser Systeme ausnutzt. Das heißt also, ich benutze halt mein Telefon, und da sind ganz viele Daten drauf. Und die Telefone werden so gebaut, dass irgendwie andere Kriminelle und so weiter dann hier halt nicht drauf zugreifen können, sondern nur ich mit meinem PIN-Code und so weiter. Das heißt, das Telefon ist sehr gut abgesichert gegen jegliche Zugriffe von außen. Und jetzt kommen halt die Sicherheitsbehörden und sagen, ja, aber unser Zugriff ist doch legitim. Und dann sagt aber die IT-Security des Telefons, nee, kein Zugriff ist legitim. Also sagen die Sicherheitsbehörden, gut, dann müssen wir halt Probleme ausnutzen in dieser Verteidigung der Telefone kann man so ein bisschen ausformulieren. Also mein Smartphone macht den Amitlern keine Tür auf oder so. Die können nicht anklopfen und sagen, hallo, hier ist meine Marke, ich bin ein Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutzmitarbeiter, bitte lass mich rein. Nein, diese Menschen müssen es schaffen auf, naja, in dem Fall dann gar nicht mehr illegal im Wege, aber auf nicht vorgesehenem Wege das Telefon zu knacken. Exakt, genau. Also sie müssen halt existierende Sicherheitslücken finden und dann ausnutzen. Also das, was eigentlich auch Menschen machen, die Technik hacken, um böse Dinge zu tun. Exakt, das ist genau der gleiche, das ist genau der Punkt. Und das heißt an der Stelle, wo kommen denn diese Sicherheitslücken überhaupt her? Also entweder, man kann die irgendwie selber suchen, das ist ja grad so das, was mit diesem ZITES funktioniert, für alle Interessierten, die das mal nachgoogeln wollen oder mit der Suchmaschine des Vertrauens. ZITES ist, das ist sozusagen so eine Behörde, die sich jetzt auf die Suche von Sicherheitslücken spezialisiert und dann allen anderen Behörden, die sowas brauchen, das bereitstellt. Das ist jetzt eine Kurzzusammenfassung. Der Chef ist ein Geheimdienstler, weiß man auch, woher es kommt. Und jetzt kann man halt diese Lücken suchen. Und jetzt gibt es eine interessante Sache, wenn man sich mal drüber nachdenkt. Wenn diese Leute so eine Lücke suchen, was sie dann wissen, ist, dass es diese Lücke gibt. Sie haben da nicht rausgefunden, wer noch davon weiß. Das heißt also, man findet da ein Problem und sagt dann, wir wissen, da gibt es eine Unsicherheit, aber wir machen die mit Absicht nicht zu, weil wir die selber noch verwenden wollen. Das heißt also, aktiv wird dafür gesorgt, dass irgendwie unsere digitale Infrastruktur, weil Handys, Rechner stecken in Autos, in Kernkraftwerke, in Flugzeugen und so weiter, wird halt gesagt, wir wollen in Einzelfällen das noch ausnutzen und deswegen lassen wir die jetzt offen. Oder in anderen Fällen, wenn man die nicht selber sucht, da kann man die auch auf dem Schwarzmarkt quasi global kaufen. Und das sind natürlich ganz shady Buden, die das so weltweit, die halt immer diesen Sicherheitslücken handeln. Und das heißt, die Idee dabei ist immer zu sagen, in einem Einzelfall brauchen wir das und dafür sorgen wir dafür, dass weltweit alle Systeme, die auch diese Lücke haben, weiterhin verwundbar bleiben. Also man könnte ja meinen, dass eine staatliche Stelle, die mit sehr viel Geld und sehr viel Expertise ausgestattet ist, und sich auf die Suche macht nach Sicherheitslücken, eine findet und dann dem Hersteller Bescheid sagt, Achtung, wir sehen eine Gefährderung unserer Bürger, schließt mal bitte diese Sicherheitslücke. Was aber passiert ist, die sagen niemandem Bescheid, weil sie die Lücke selber gebrauchen können, um sich da selber reinzuhacken, wissen aber nicht, ob nicht, weil das natürlich nicht nur denen möglich ist, Sicherheitslücken zu finden, irgendwelche anderen, die auch schon gefunden haben, sie genauso benutzen und dann Dinge tun, die deutlich mehr wehtun als das, was die Verfassungsschützer zum Beispiel machen. Exakt, genau, das ist genau der Punkt. Und da haben wir es aber auch wieder mit dem Problem zu tun, dass jetzt die jeweiligen Polizeien und Verfassungsschützer und Ämter und so weiter, die sehen halt immer nur ihre kleine Welt und sagen, ja, wir wollen doch aber in dieses Telefon rein. Ob jetzt mit dieser gleichen Lücke, die man von irgendeinem Laden gekauft hat, parallel in Bareien gerade irgendwelche Dissidenten zu Hause abgeholt werden und die Familien verschwinden, weil was die gleiche Lücke ist, da sagen die halt, und ich kenne das halt auch aus Gesprächen, da sagen die halt, ja, also Bareien ist halt weit weg. Also es ist halt, wir wollen uns interessiert, was in Deutschland passiert und wir wollen jetzt hier in dieses Telefon und das ist natürlich, ich meine, was ist denn das für ein Welt- und Menschenbild da irgendwie mitzuhelfen, dass auf der anderen Seite des Planeten irgendwelche Leute, die für Freiheit kämpfen, da irgendwie in den Gassen zu Klump geprügelt werden. Da sieht man halt nur den eigenen Teller und guckt aber nicht über den Rand hinaus, was das für riesengrasse Auswirkungen weltweit hat an der Stelle. Wie ist denn das rechtlich? Was darf ein Bundestrojaner beispielsweise? Das ist doch bestimmt in sehr engen Maßstäben alles gesetzt. Also es gibt da tatsächlich eine lustige Spezifiziertheit darin. Man unterscheidet bei diesen Bundestrojanern eigentlich im Wesentlichen zwei. Die eine ist die ausgewachsene, erwachsene Online-Durchsuchung. Die darf im Endeffekt alles. Die darf die Festplatte durchsuchen, die darf angeschlossene Geräte aktivieren oder Speicher aktivieren und so weiter. Und die hat sehr, sehr hohe Eingriffswürden. Und dann gibt es aber noch so ein interessantes Konstrukt. Das ist sozusagen so ein rechtliches Konstrukt, was sagt, ja, dann haben wir aber noch so eine Online-Durchsuchung Leid oder so ein Staats-Trojaner Leid. Der bricht auch in diese, der infiltriert so ein System. Aber der, ich sag's jetzt mal in menschlichen Worten, der verspricht ganz, ganz dolle, dass er aber auch nur Kommunikationsdaten ausleitet und die anderen Sachen möglichst nicht anfasst. Und dann gibt es eben so einen rechtlichen Kniff, der sagt, naja gut, also wenn der Trojaner da drauf ist auf diesem Gerät und nicht rechts guckt und nicht links guckt, sondern nur die Kommunikationsdaten an sich betrachtet, dann ist der gar nicht so schlimm. Dann sind wir gar nicht in das System so wirklich ganz eingebrochen, sondern nur ein bisschen. Das kommt ja auch so ein bisschen aus der Geschichte, die du von schon gesagt hast. Früher hat man irgendwie telefoniert zum Beispiel und konnte sozusagen mitlesen, was in diesem Moment linear durch irgendeine Leitung durchfließt. Jetzt gerade werden Worte gesagt, die kann ich mithören und mitschreiben und dann weiß ich, was da abgesprochen wurde. Das ist Telekommunikationsüberwachung, die gibt es immer noch. Und so heißt glaube ich auch immer noch dieses eine Ding, was du gerade meintest, was quasi die Light-Variante ist. Genau, die Quellen-TKÜ. Das Problem ist dann ja aber, dass es heutzutage auf Smartphones, Computern, allen möglichen Geräten so ist, dass die Kommunikation, die in der Vergangenheit liegt, ja eigentlich gespeichert worden ist. Und dass man da riesige Chat-Verläufe nachlesen kann und Anhänge, die verschickt worden sind, irgendwo auf einer Festplatte finden kann. Und deswegen ist die Überwachung, die auf solchen Rechnern stattfinden kann, viel, viel krassere, als eine reine lineare Telekommunikationsüberwachung, weil ich kann eben nicht nur mitlesen, jetzt gerade erzählt mir jemand beim Telefon das und das oder jetzt gerade schreibt mir jemand dieses jenes, sondern ich kann eigentlich alles durchsuchen, was auf einer Festplatte liegt. Korrekt, genau. Also der Zugriff ist, also da gibt es sozusagen zwei Stufen des Problems. Die erste Stufe ist natürlich irgendwie, wenn man da auf die Kommunikationsdaten zugreift, hat man auch Zugriff auf die vergangenen Informationen und so weiter. Genau. Und technisch gesehen hat man auch Zugriff auf alle anderen Daten. Aber wie gesagt, man verspricht ja hoch und heilig, dass man die nicht durchsucht. Genau, weil also der Punkt ist ja, man hat eigentlich für beide Varianten, für die Quellentheke, die Kommunikation bewachen, die irgendwie die die breien geht und für die die Leitvariante quasi. Du musst beide Male ein Loch finden, du musst beidemal das Loch knacken und du kommst beide Male tief ins System rein und der Unterschied ist eigentlich nur, dass du einmal sagst, nee, ich guck mir nichts anderes an. Bestimmt nicht. Richtig, genau. Und es gibt aber noch ein zweites, das kann man sich auch relativ gut vorstellen. Ein zweites Problem neben dieser History, auf die man halt zugreifen kann. Wenn ich verschlüsselte Kommunikation abhören will, dann muss ich die ja abfangen, bevor sie verschickt wird. Jetzt ist es technisch so, es ist nur so ein kleiner Kniff, den man verstehen muss, um zu sehen, warum diese rechtliche Unterscheidung Unsinn ist. Ich verschlüssel meine Nachricht und dann schiebe ich die halt quasi durch mein Kommunikationsmedium. Jetzt ist es so, dass dieses Verschicken und das Verschlüsseln ist nicht der gleiche Vorgang. Das heißt also, ich muss es erst verschlüsseln und dann sehr wahrscheinlich verschicken. Kann man sich so ein bisschen vorstellen, ich habe eine Mail, die ist im Entwurfsordner, die schreibe ich und irgendwann entscheide ich mich dazu, die aus dem Entwurfsordner tatsächlich auch zu verschicken. Oder ich schreibe einen Brief und dann muss ja noch im Umschlag zugeklebt werden und dann erst keine Einschassen geworfen werden. Exakt, genau, richtig. Jetzt ist es allerdings so, damit ich das auch wirklich mit so einem Trojaner ausleiten kann, bevor die Kiste zugemacht wird, bevor das verschlüsselt wird, bevor das in den Umschlag getan wird, muss ich natürlich eine Kopie anlegen, dessen im Klartext, ich will es ja gerade haben, das unverschlüsselte. Und wenn jetzt die Benutzer nach der Verschlüsselung sagen, ich will es ja doch nicht abschicken, sondern schmeißen dann den Entwurf weg, dann hat halt diese Software einen Klartext erfasst, der nie verschickt worden ist. Und dann ist es eben doch wieder nicht nur die Überwachung der laufenden Telekommunikation, sondern es ist dann eigentlich der gleiche Eingriff in die Speichersysteme, weil es in der laufenden Kommunikation überhaupt nicht mehr möglich wäre, mitzulesen, weil die ist ja schon verschlüsselt. Genau. Und das war jetzt nur ein Beispiel. Also ich könnte da eine Reihe von diesen konzeptionellen Problemen anführen. Wir lassen uns aber glaube ich bei diesem Beispiel, wo man halt merkt, da gibt es einfach grundsätzlich ein konzeptionelles Problem. Und das erkennt man aber erst, wenn man, ich sage jetzt mal, technischen Sachverstand hat. Und wenn man sich sozusagen die Freude anschaut, sozusagen der Sicherheitsbehörden, juhu, wir können jetzt WhatsApp mitlesen, dann sagen die halt toll, wir können jetzt auch eine andere Art von SMS mitlesen. Und sehen aber gerade gar nicht, was da im Hintergrund eigentlich passiert und was sie da für Löcher in unsere digitale Infrastruktur reißen, weil sie konzeptiell das nicht nachvollziehen können. Weiß man, wie relevant das ist? Also wie oft das passiert, wie viele Angriffe es per Bundestrojaner zum Beispiel gibt? Also es gibt bei der vollen Online-Durchsuchung, das sind irgendwie ein paar Dutzend oder so, da gibt es so ein paar Zahlen. Das Problem ist so ein bisschen bei dieser Quellen-TKÜ, dass die nicht so richtig, ich hab da auch jetzt eine IFG-Anfrage am Laufen gehabt, die wird halt nicht so richtig unterschieden von der normalen TKÜ. Also sozusagen eigentlich müsste man das unterscheiden, um das dann zu betrachten, wie oft das tatsächlich verwendet wird. Aber in deren Denkweise ist es ja eigentlich nur sozusagen eine Telekom-Überwachung mit anderen Mitteln. Und deswegen wird das halt nicht so richtig unterschieden. Und dadurch kann man das auch gar nicht sagen. Und ich will auch eine Sache noch, die mir sehr, sehr wichtig ist dabei sagen. Weil ich dieses Argument auch öfters höre mit Vertretern dieser Sicherheitsbehörden. Man kann das jetzt so pragmatisch diskutieren. Aber ich finde, da wird halt eine Grenze überschritten. Man würde ja auch nicht sagen, ja Folter ist schon okay, wenn es irgendwie fünfmal im Jahr stattfindet. Also da muss man sich irgendwie darüber nahe, muss man sich darüber klar werden, dass wir hier über viel mehr reden, als diesen einen konkreten Punkt. Weil diese eine Sicherheitslücke, die da verwendet wird, vielleicht verwenden wir die nur einmal im Jahr. Aber in Bahrain wird die halt 20 mal irgendwie im Monat angewendet. Ein Dissident nach dem anderen. Und das sind einfach so Sachen, da muss man sich sozusagen dieser grundsätzlichen Problematik auch bewusst werden. Das hat so eine IT-Sicherheitsfrage, aber es hat eben auch was damit zu tun, nach irgendwie den Grundwerten unserer Gesellschaft. Wollen wir auf Kosten von den Leuten auf der anderen Seite der Erde, die uns nicht so richtig interessieren, wollen wir dafür ab und zu mal ein bisschen BTM, also Betäubungsmittelkriminalität oder irgendwie Asylmissbrauch, darf ein paar Fälle aufklären, ist es das irgendwie wert? Also unserer Ansicht nach natürlich nicht. Und was noch dazu kommt bei diesen grundsätzlichen Fragen, also diese Technik, die ist halt unglaublich teuer. Diese Lücken, wenn die ein paar mal benutzt werden, dann werden die vielleicht geschlossen. Die Software ändert sich, kann man sich überlegen, wie viel oft mal mal sein Betriebssystem updatet und so weiter. Da gehen, das kennen wir ja irgendwie bei so einen IT Großprojekten, da gehen halb Millionen rein. Und jetzt kann man sich mal überlegen, wie viel könnte man denn bei sozialer Prävention im Schulbereich, Jugendclubs, was weiß ich, wie viel kann man damit ein paar Millionen machen im Vergleich dazu zu so einen noch nicht mal technisch gut gebauten Sachen, die jetzt irgendwie in Deutschland hergestellt werden oder die da irgendwie gekauft werden. Also sozusagen die Relation ist einfach total krass, weil man sich in den Kopf gesetzt hat, man macht jetzt ganz toll Digitalisierung mit und verliert so ein bisschen die Verbindung des Problems, was man da eigentlich gerade lösen will, nämlich irgendwie eine sichere Gesellschaft schaffen. Und wir von FIFF, also ich meine, wir finden auch eine sichere Gesellschaft gut, aber nicht wie beim Südkreuz, nicht mit diesen vorgeschobenen, hingeschobenen, schrägen Gedanken. Ich finde interessant, wir kommen jetzt, wo ihr so eure Sicht erläutert, auf dieses Thema oder auch gerade schon beim Südkreuz immer an den Punkt, wo man eigentlich merkt, ja, okay, wir könnten über die konkrete Umsetzung von dieser und jener Sicherheitsmaßnahme jetzt sprechen. Aber eigentlich reden wir über Probleme, die viel tiefer und viel früher passieren. Konzeptionelle Sachen, die in diesen beiden Themen, wie die Überwachung mit Gesichtserkennung am Bahnhof Südkreuz in der Testversion, wo man bei ihr beide Male sagt, das ist einfach von Grund auf falsch gedacht. Und es gibt da einfach von Grund auf so große Probleme, an denen so ein langer Rattenschwanz dranhängt, dass man beide Sachen bleiben lassen sollte. Genau, also das Spannende, genau was du sagst, da ist halt ein bestimmtes Muster, was sich ständig wiederholt. Und wir lernen ja auch irgendwie, das FIFF ist halt irgendwie jetzt ein paar Dekaden alt. Da wiederholt sich immer wieder, kommt irgendwie eine neue Technik und dann gibt es so die harten Probleme, die sozialen Probleme mit irgendwie Ausgrenzung und Bildung und so weiter. Und dann kommt da eine Technik um die Ecke, egal ob es künstliche Intelligenz ist oder Staatshacking oder irgendwie Blockchain oder was weiß ich. Und dann sagt man, oh toll, endlich können wir das lösen. Endlich können wir diese harten Probleme runter reduzieren auf irgendwie ein bisschen Software, die man schreibt und dann da anwendet. Und dann sind wir das endlich los. Dann vergehen fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn Jahre. Und dann merkt man irgendwie hinten fällt es runter, niemand redet mehr drüber und dann kommt das nächste angewandert. Und dann merkt man an der Stelle, dass Technik, sozusagen diese technische Sichtweise auch so ein bisschen einfach die Birne vernebelt. Und das ist natürlich, gerade das ist auch so meiner Ansicht nach eine Stärke von Technikerinnen und Technikern, die sich so ein bisschen mit Gesellschaft beschäftigen. Man weiß halt oder man weiß eben nicht nur, wofür Sachen eingesetzt werden können, sondern man kennt auch die Grenzen. Und es geht jetzt auch nicht darum zu sagen, wir wollen zurück in die Höhle und irgendwie war ja toll, als es noch irgendwie Fackeln gab, sondern es geht darum zu sagen, wenn wir Technik richtig gut einsetzen wollen, dann müssen wir wissen, wo die Chancen und Risiken sind, um mal so einen Allgemeinplatz zu bedienen, um zu wissen, da setzen wir es ein und da kann man es richtig gut einsetzen und das kann es aber auch nicht. Deswegen lassen wir es lieber und versenken da nicht irgendwie Millionen in irgendwelchen Ecken, die an anderer Stelle viel, viel sinnvoller eingesetzt werden. Und da sind bei den Projekten die Prioritäten falsch gesetzt, sozusagen. Exakt.
Technik hat halt auch immer einen bestimmten Ruf, vor allen Dingen Informationstechnik. Das ist irgendwie wie Magie, das verstehen die meisten nicht so. Man hat halt irgendein Problem, ein soziales Problem vielleicht sogar oder ein Sicherheitsproblem und dann schmeißt man da irgendwie Technik drauf und vielleicht viel Geld und viel Know-how und versucht das irgendwie dadurch zu lösen. Aber ein Sicherheitsproblem löst man vielleicht eben nicht durch Technik. Technik hat auch immer so diesen Unfehlbarkeitsanschein. Und Technik hat immer diesen Anschein, als ob das sich so ganz linear entwickelt. Also das ist einfach nur immer der nächste Schritt. Und man verbessert das, was halt irgendwie, was halt als nächstes zwangsläufig kommen muss. Also die Computer werden halt schneller und genauer und genauer und schneller und kleiner und besser und so weiter. Aber es gibt halt bestimmte Richtungen, wie man Technik auch gestalten will. Und genau darüber denkt das FIFF halt auch ganz viel nach. Also was wollen wir mit der Technik überhaupt machen? Und wie wollen wir die so gestalten, dass die halt irgendwie auch wieder zurückstrahlt in die Gesellschaft? Und eben dieser lineare Glaube daran, dass das halt alles so kommen muss und immer besser wird, führt dann eben auch dazu, dass man zum Teil Techniken einführt oder benutzen will. Und dann halt irgendwie dauernd so Argumente kommen. Na ja, das funktioniert jetzt noch nicht so gut, aber wir können es ja schon mal irgendwie installieren. Und dann glauben sogar viele Informatiker selbst wahrscheinlich daran, dass das dann einfach in den nächsten zehn Jahren so viel besser wird, dass es dann einfach versprochen wird, ja, wir arbeiten dran und dann wird die Gesichtserkennung halt total gut. Oder irgendwie, wir machen das, dass der Trojaner total ethisch korrekt funktioniert und halt irgendwie gar keine Fehler hat oder sowas. Und diese Gläubigkeit daran ist halt total irreführend. Und wenn man sich selber mit Technik beschäftigt, sieht man das auch nicht.
Da gibt es so einen Spruch, was das zusammenfasst, in the future everything will work. Sehr schön, dass wir den Bundestrojaner Sack auf diese Weile jetzt zumachen konnten. Wir haben echt nur noch knappe 10 Minuten. Deswegen müssen wir mal ein bisschen in die Pötte kommen hier im Chaosradio. Du hast gerade schon gesagt, das sind so die großen Dinge, mit denen sich das FIFF auch in Zukunft bestimmt weiter beschäftigen wird. Wenn wir mal in die nähere Zukunft gucken, es gibt bald was, da kann man euch auch angucken und anfassen. Die FIFF-Con. Na, sag mal.
Ja, wir haben seit vielen, vielen Jahren eine Jahrestagung. Die ist in den letzten Jahren umgetauft zur FIFF-Con. Also FIFF-Conference mit K. Allerdings. Ein deutscher Verein. Die findet dieses Jahr auch wieder in Berlin statt.
Brave New World ist der Titel.
Genau. Den Untertitel, unseren großen Untertitel ausländisch.
Klar. Freiheitsgrad und Machtmuster sozio-technischer Systeme. Das ist ein sehr, kommt sehr...
Gestaltungsfreiheiten und Machtmuster sozio-technischer Systeme. Exakt.
Das kommt so ein bisschen wissenschaftlicher daher. Aber eigentlich die Zusammenfassung, haben wir vorhin schon ein bisschen umrissen, ist eigentlich, wir sollten nicht die Technik fragen, wie wir jetzt weitergehen, sondern wir sollten uns fragen, wobei uns die Technik helfen will und helfen soll weiterzugehen. Und da gibt es nämlich viel mehr Freiraum und Freimöglichkeiten, die uns irgendwie Informationstechnik anbietet und die wollen wir jetzt auch mal irgendwie ausschöpfen und wollen mal gucken an der Stelle, wollen wir eine zentralisierte Zukunft, dann bauen wir halt zentralisierte Systeme. Wollen wir eine dezentrale Zukunft, dann bauen wir halt auch dezentrale Systeme. Okay, aber warte, warte, das sind wieder diese großen Fragen. Was wird konkret passieren? Gibt es dann Vorträge? Konkret, ja klar, konkret, also es gibt Vorträge, das geht so irgendwie so ein bisschen Techies, Techies werden darüber sprechen, wie so Systeme aussehen, welche Werte sie vertreten und so weiter. Es gibt Workshops, es gibt auch wieder eine schöne Party, es gibt auch so ein bisschen Kulturprogramm, es gibt Essen, Trinken, gute Kekse, Kaffee und die Vorträge, ja also die Leute, die wir bis jetzt so im Auge haben, da geht es so quasi Informatiker und Informatiker, Leute aus den Politikwissenschaften, Soziologie, ein bisschen Philosophie auch, um das so zusammenzubauen und dann kann man halt, wenn man sich eben für die größeren Fragen interessiert, kann man eher in die eine Art von Vorträgen gehen und wenn man sich eher so fürs konkrete Handfeste interessiert, dann kann man halt auch zu den techigeren Veranstaltungen gehen. Creo, kommst du auch?
Die Berliner Tagungen sind besondere Höhepunkte, aber ich war eigentlich praktisch zu allen Tagungen der letzten Jahre.
Was ist da schön bei den Tagungen?
Ja, erstens mal, dass man viele interessante Dinge, die man ja nicht selber alle wissen kann, hört und mit vielen netten Leuten zusammentrifft und eben ganz spannende Themen, die uns noch lange beschäftigen werden, schon mal von verschiedenen Seiten hier diskutieren kann.
Wann und wo?
Ben?
Die FIFCON findet statt vom 28. bis 30. September 2018 in Berlin. Der Ort ist noch geheim.
Ja, wir machen hier so einen Spannungsboden.
Aus Gründen.
Das ist, wenn ich das richtig sehe, 28. bis 30. September, Freitag bis Sonntag, also eine gemütliche Wochenendfahrt.
Genau, das wird auch ringsrum, das wird auch eine ganz besondere Woche hier in Berlin, da wird auch noch ringsrum die Privacy Week Berlin stattfinden.
Das ist auch da, genau.
Es gibt auch noch von der GI eine Jahrestagung, die auch ein paar Tage vorher stattfindet. Dann gibt es vom Arbeitskreis Ethik und Informatik von der GI auch noch einen Arbeitskreis. Das ist also alles in dieser Woche. Man sollte also überlegen, ob man sich dafür freinimmt oder ob es vielleicht Bildungsurlaub oder sowas gibt. Im Prinzip ist die FIFFcon eine Mischung aus Chaos-Veranstaltungen, Fusion und wissenschaftlichem Kongress. Gibt es auch Musik? Auf jeden Fall.
Ja, natürlich. Es gibt schönes Licht und auch Musik.
Und gute Kekse.
Ja, genau. Also man kann glaube ich sagen, die FIFFcon, eine Art der Beschreibung wäre wie eine wissenschaftliche Tagung, bloß ohne das Krankenhauslicht. Oder man könnte sagen, es ist die Fusion, bloß mit ein bisschen Hervorträgen oder so. Man kann das so ein bisschen die Richtung. Hey, ich will wissen, wo das ist. Ihr seid ja frech, mir das nicht zu verraten. Das klingt alles schon so plastisch.
Also die letzten Jahre hat es im TU-Mattegebäude stattgefunden.
Und dann habt ihr das TU-Mattegebäude, was erstmal ja krass nach Krankenhauslicht klingt, einfach mal schön umgebaut und gepimpt.
Man kann ja mal auf fifcon.de gehen, dann wird es gleich umgeleitet auf die 2018er Subdomain. Also 2018.fifcon.de. Und da gibt es dann so ein paar Bilder und links zu den anderen Konferenzen sieht man, was man aus dem Gebäude auch machen kann.
Eine Sache würde ich noch gerne hinzufügen, was ich persönlich auch so schön finde an diesen Veranstaltungen und vielleicht ähnlichen. Aber wenn man so täglich Nachrichten liest und so weiter, denkt man immer so, hier auch alles furchtbar und irgendwie wird alles schlimmer und schon wieder hier in Trojaner und da schon wieder. Und da soll man mal auch nicht vergessen und das merkt man immer bei solchen Veranstaltungen, da rennen ganz viele Leute rum, die ganz viele coole Sachen machen und die auch erfolgreich sind in ganz vielen Richtungen. Und da merkt man irgendwie, man ist eben auch nicht alleine mit diesen Aktionen. Und da kriegt man eben nicht so diesen verklebten traurigen Blick, sondern merkt so krass, natürlich verkaufen sich schlechte Nachrichten besser als gute und wer weiß, wo die Welt hingeht. Aber dass man auch so ein bisschen neben der ganzen Schreibtischarbeit und neben der ganzen, was man da so mit seinem Rechner in dunklen Kellern mit sich treibt und schöne Projekte macht usw. das mal mit anderen zusammen zu durchquatschen und vielleicht auch mal beim Kaltgetränk einfach mal zu gucken, dass man nicht alleine ist, sondern dass wir ziemlich viele sind und immer mehr werden und dass da noch lange nichts verloren ist. Das ist die FIFF-Con Ende September in Berlin. Jetzt kann aber auch jeder, wenn er da Bock hat, sich noch ein bisschen mehr einzubringen, ja auch Mitglied im FIFF werden.
Ja, genau.
Und warum sollte ich das tun? Und überhaupt?
Ja, also man hat auf jeden Fall unglaublich viele Möglichkeiten, sein Wissen und Know-how einzubringen. Also es geht auch gar nicht eben wie gesagt, man muss nicht sein Diplom-Zeugnis oder irgendwas vorzeigen, sondern wir haben, wir suchen auch immer wieder Menschen, die einfach zum Beispiel auf der FIFCON irgendwie helfen, das mit zu organisieren, designen. Es gibt ganz, ganz viele To-Do's.
Also eine Grundinteresse für Informatik und Gesellschaft sollte vorhanden sein.
Genau.
Also man kann auch, wenn man sagt, warum sollte man auch Mitglied werden? Also erstens, man kriegt halt dieses schöne Heft, Haus, frei Haus zugesendet und muss sich um nichts mehr kümmern, muss es nicht irgendwie irgendwo abholen und so weiter. Da sind auch mal schöne, schöne Sticker drin und so weiter. Außerdem, wenn man die Sachen cool findet, die wir machen, dann kann man ja auch einfach sagen, ich habe da jetzt nicht immer Lust, irgendwie in die Spar-Dose was reinzulegen, sondern ich werde Mitglied.
Das ist 70 Euro.
70 Euro im Jahr, genau.
Aber 20 für Studierende. Guter Punkt.
Und dann kann man auch einfach sagen, cool, was die machen, finde ich gut. Und da helfe ich auch einfach gerne mit. Und wenn man mal auf eine von unseren Veranstaltungen kommt, dann sagt man, hey cool, ich bin auch vom FIFF und man denkt sich super cool. Und weil da keine Videoüberwachung ist bei uns, kann man sich auch herzlich mal in die Arme fallen. Und ich bekomme wahrscheinlich das Formular und die Infos auch auf eurer Webseite fiff.de.
FIFF.de, genau.
f-i-doppel-f.de, wo ich auch nochmal nachlesen kann, ob ich eure Arbeit eigentlich cool finde, sollte ich das in den letzten zwei Stunden hier im Chaosradio noch nicht herausgefunden haben.
Genau. Es gibt noch ein paar andere Informationsquellen. Wir haben mehrere Twitter-Accounts zu Cyberpeace, eben dieser Südkreuz-Account. Wir haben auch für die FIFF-Konferenz einen Account, der heißt einfach fiffconn. Wir haben unsere ganzen letzten Konferenzen, kann man auch nachschauen. Da hat uns das Vogue vom CCC ganz großartig unterstützt. Also die letzten Konferenzen findet man unter media.ccc.de. Also auch, wir haben einen eigenen Channel dort bekommen, die FIFF-Kon. Die Videos von der letzten Jahrestagung, vom November, die kommen jetzt auch in den nächsten Tagen online. Die sind fertig. Die Website und demnächst kommt dann eben auch noch dieses FIFF-Kommunikation. Also unser Magazin wird dann auch online gebracht.
Stimmt, das ist der nächste große Schritt in Richtung Magazin auch endlich.
Creo wollte noch was sagen.
Ja, ich würde mich freuen, wenn noch viel, viel mehr, wir sind ja schon ein paar hundert, aber es könnten ruhig auch noch mehr werden im FIFF, denn es gibt ja Zehntausende, die sich mit Informatik rumschlagen und wenn die dann noch mehr gucken würden, was mit ihren Produkten gemacht wird, da könnten wir also durchaus noch Verstärkung gebrauchen.
Sehr schön, dann ist es ja Aufruf gewesen, fif.de, da gibt es die Infos und damit sind wir am Ende vom Chaos Radio Nummer 245, heute mit dem Forum Informatikerinnen für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung, kurz FIFF. Da waren Ben, vielen Dank.
Ja wunderbar.
Rainer, danke dir. Danke schön auch. Creo, danke, in die Nähe von Bremen. Mit FIFFigen Grüßen, sehr schön. Das Chaos Radio gibt es wie immer auch zum Nachhören, media.ccc.de, ja war richtig, auch da sind wir zu finden. Und dann im nächsten Monat, also heute quasi in einem Monat, wie der Donnerstagabend, dann wieder live und auch im Programm von Fritz zu hören. Ich bin Konrad Spremberg. Sehr schön, dass ihr da wart und alle da draußen habt einen schönen Abend. You know how all those bad boy rappers Trekkie Birthdays das, wie immer zum Schluss vom Chaos Radio mit Website.